okay so this dude went out bought a
[ __ ] on the hand sanitizer 18,000
bottles and because he wanted to seize
the opportunity that he saw is a
[ __ ] and then he can't sell it now
I'm ready to fum rate a fire on this
fool let's go let's [ __ ] go Oh panic
buying has been on the rise a minute was
he was he whoever captured this picture
this [ __ ] is life style is [ __ ]
yeah like this borderline looks like the
first page to like a Thrasher Magazine
such a great shot yeah global spread of
the new coronavirus with consumers
around the world stockpiling goods like
hand sanitizer canned foods and toilet
paper including one man in Hickson it's
a story that is dominating national
headlines after the owlets
let's calm down with that word what I
want to say he was dominated all right
he had a little you know he had he had a
little moment yeah one of these dominant
dominating headlines now yeah I think
the virus itself probably yes dominant
was the one dominating the head yeah
yeah this does do that a little yeah a
little shout yeah yeah yeah a little
single yeah if he is five minutes yeah
the New York Times wrote about Matt
Colvin stockpiling goods amid the corona
virus outbreak channel three's hunter
Hoagland talked to Matt who bought
nearly 18,000 bottles of hand sanitizer
18,000 why would you even agree to this
interview yeah like I mean you know you
know he why he needs to sell the yeah
that's why yeah yeah he's got to get rid
of yeah while many are still searching
to find even one for Matt Colvin a
pandemic meant an opportunity for Matt
Colvin a pandemic meant an opportunity
that's that's the worst [ __ ] phrase
yeah a pandemic meant an opportunity oh
no oh never look I'm trying to wear this
shirt to make up for it this is like the
this is like the best bit I've ever seen
no I'm just a family man
running a family business what about the
families that don't have hand sanitizer
right now they could have it if they hit
a family man family business yeah that's
the big bad corporation Amazon that
won't let me do exactly went to zero to
sixty really fast after the first Cove
819 death in the United States
Colvin whence what do they get these
news people with this voice yeah I don't
know after the first day to death they
don't ah if you die and this is the guy
talking about your death the first death
after coded nineteen this is a
disrespectful
yeah he's rolling around in your grave
like yeah but some respect online the
first death at the nineteen [ __ ] up you
nerd
stop talking about me keep my name out
of your mouth wait hold on go back for a
second wait so this guy I just want to
point out this guy after the first death
he saw the first person died and then he
was like now's the time to strike what a
psych-out an [ __ ] dick after the
first covet damn death in the United
States
Colvin went state to state clearing out
sanitizers the way this guy talks it's
like his mouth is like a kid's like the
teeth are always showing Calvin went to
another state yeah and he's like always
congested it was a little bit nasally
and you know it's like Calvin went to
him you like talk to the table knows
shelves he went to many spoons and he go
after the first death from cope at 19
this [ __ ] is reading this [ __ ] at a
yacht club laughing at poor people
clearing out sanitizer shelves he now
sits with 18,000 unused empty barrels in
storage unit gave him out Duty Valley
struggle to find one ah the bulk of it
was purchased with just driving around
to retail stores in the Chattanooga area
Colvin bought the sanitizer with the
intention of selling them for profit on
Amazon before they took his listings
down now feeling the same pain
as many others oh crap is the PG way to
say it though he would not discuss on
camera the exact prices he sold the
sanitizer for he told the New York Times
in a recent interview that andis so
funny to him items were listed at $70 a
bottle he's selling this [ __ ] for 70
bucks
what a [ __ ] are you man
smart smart mark them up yeah their
margins yeah see that opportunity charge
seven thousand percent margin you know
yeah like an airline ticket mm-hm you
know cuz when what do you see when when
you hear pandemic what do you see in
your head um dead people are suffering
yeah
depression la blah blah I see
opportunity hmm yeah yeah and that's why
I put family business I gotta hear this
[ __ ] all not the pricing on Amazon was
higher than it was definitely higher
than retail stating in a shirt that says
my definitely her stuff we are family
man family business family man family
business he says he never anticipated
the struggle other families would go
through because of a shortage [ __ ] off
say you're sorry
this is it sorry for purchase sorry for
buying all of this
no I don't think that I would oh oh what
a dick Double Down row the diplomatic
pause - holy [ __ ] day he had a real that
was kind of [ __ ] hard I was a that
was kind of tough
we're all waiting with bated breath is
he gonna say is he is this man sorry for
what he did ya know you're a family man
are you sorry that other families are
you've put other families in jeopardy
essentially because they don't have any
sanitizer and now might get the virus
and you know yeah na yeah na I'm alright
love ya thank you a good love thank you
what if he doesn't even have a family
yeah the sound of that baby in the
background is just like a [ __ ] like a
fake baby monitor set up all this [ __ ]
to seem like a family man that I would
after receding back as long as my family
says he's making plans to donate the
rest of the sanitized wood business
there's wins and there's losses of
course and this is one a situation where
cutting my cutting my losses is the
right thing to do
nice okay what was that oh they like
they just edited the interview real [ __ ]
hold on I wanted to own do some math and
that I'm using calculator this time cuz
we all know that when I do math after
just waking up it doesn't work out very
well yeah eighteen thousand hold on one
second wait once are you doing man
we're gonna take a quick break we are
yeah alright we're back
[Laughter]
ATM like some [ __ ] Avengers [ __ ]
right there
we're gonna take a break we are are we
18,000 times have it was seven to
seventeen thousand seven hundred so
multiply that by $299 know what I'm just
what's the average price to 90 well he
said he was selling them for 70 bucks a
bottle
wait no no let's I want to get his cost
we just cost in the kit so we're
calculating profit yeah that's okay
let's average cost everything cuz he's
got like okay we'll just do well just
five bucks bucks for a bottle sanitizer
cuz he's got different sizes right yeah
so them so ones this was like if some
are five dollars that he purchase them
for and somewhere like three you think
that most is five bucks isn't it kind of
expensive like you get a big bottle like
this yeah maybe it's like seven books
yes it's nothing averaged four bucks
four bucks let's say I like five okay
every five you got eighty nine thousand
dollars potentially of a hand sanitizer
damn oh my god that's actually that's
actually [ __ ] absurd this guy [ __ ]
loaded yeah what the maybe he like took
out a loan or something oh my a small oh
if he just conned the bank he's like
yeah I need a small business loan yeah
for what I'm starting a drop ship or bet
you he saw some tick tock it all started
with yeah yeah probably is like pandemic
coming want to know how to make some
money buy some hand sanitizer from
Alibaba listed on eBay
30 take some marketing pictures yeah and
you're rich and you're rich and it's a
17 year old kid like swinging hundreds
and [ __ ] and he's like dude I can
[ __ ] do that I can buy a hundred
thousand dollars worth of any fact I
will okay so now he was selling them for
okay
so 17 seven hundred times seventy -
eighty nine thousand you would have made
him off cool milli off this [ __ ] dude
nine hundred thousand dollars
potentially he could have made
oh and now I'm seeing the opportunity
like what a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
what of [ __ ] know who did he's
donating them okay okay okay yeah yeah
he's a good guy yeah in business know
you're a really good dude when you're
when you're good only when you're
shittiness doesn't work out yeah yeah
and it gets put on a national television
yeah and you still try to move it a
little bit yeah yeah he's like I still I
mean for anyone watching I still got it
for the low if you're if you're in I
will donate it though but if if you are
in need and in the immediate area of
Chattanooga I saw I saw the quote where
he said that he was providing a service
to everyone what service yeah yeah the
service was already done by the [ __ ]
store the story you [ __ ] [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you just took a [ __ ] on oh my
god dude
to like even get it on the Shelf you
know what I'm saying yeah but the people
who make it sell it and then the [ __ ]
purchaser from the retail chain who
mitigates that it gets it into the store
and then you want to [ __ ] come in and
buy it all and be like I'm providing a
service yeah no you didn't you [ __ ]
loser
you didn't you didn't do anything you
just took it from other people
I hope mmm I mean I hope this guy's is
his drop shipping business hits the
[ __ ] which it will yeah what a
[ __ ] dick I now did you know why did
you like how that duas was so funny oh
it's hilarious so funny it's hilarious
are you sorry yeah that part I would
give doing though yeah that [ __ ] is hard
what are the comments say yeah
hey good ones I have no sympathy for
this kind of people he seems like he
justifies it okay it's people piling it
on yeah okay I don't I don't want to get
on here and just be [ __ ] the status
quo and be like this guy's a [ __ ] M
my [ __ ] Michele this is the kind of
[ __ ] you want in other aspects of
business you know yeah you know maybe he
should he should just not be involved in
moral things yeah but this guy's a
stockbroker
yeah oh there you go yeah he's there up
there with the shittiest yeah
you